welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
vanston and the final countdown to the
Super Mario Brothers movie begins as we
are treated 2-1 final trailer that's
right after five breakdowns of different
trailers clips and posters we're back
once more to take a look at a pretty
wild amount of new footage and see what
we can parse out speaking of those five
other breakdowns if you think I missed
something obvious in this trailer just
go back and watch the other breakdowns I
probably mentioned it there that being
said there's a lot of new stuff to work
with so let's hop in and a quick
reminder to check out nerdright.shop
where you can always find our latest and
greatest merch options right now you can
grab something from our news collection
inspired by the Mandalorian support the
channel and check out all of our awesome
March options over at nerduride.shop
[Music]
ooh fresh meat for the grinder he is
cute but he is
only hope is the sweet relief of death
we have an establishing shot to show
exactly where we are cages hang from the
ceiling with captives and oh look it's
me when they drop new Mario movie news
the day after I film a video from what
we can see this prison party is 97
Penguins two percent dry bones and
Goombas you can also see more Goombas up
here with one trying to fight through
the bars and one percent Luma who we'll
get back to we've seen these penglings I
won't stop saying it in the teaser
trailer and know that this group led by
the penguin king tried to fight back
against Bowser who obliterated their
Kingdom and likely took their star but
that's unconfirmed but here we see the
aftermath below them you can also see
Bowser's Minions piloting ships and
patrolling the area it's hard to see but
some of the detailing on these round
ships make me think there's a chance
that their Koopa clown cars but they
could totally just be original Patrol
ships made for the movie back to that
adorably nihilistic Luma it's lightly
blue color and how it has a little split
at the top of its head suggests it's a
Luma Lee originally from Super Mario
Galaxy lumalis are a type of luma that
act as a sort of shop in Mario Galaxy
giving the hero either a 1up or a life
Mushroom in exchange for Star Bits that
it devours most of them is live with
Rosalina on the common Observatory so
how this little guy got captured is a
mystery but they very well may play a
part in helping Luigi since they're
helping hand in the games watching
something you love is self-care feels
good right well with geology you can
have that good feeling of self-care in
your daily routine too geology is a
16-time award-winning personalized
skincare company recognized in men's
health Esquire and ask men grooming
Awards with over 6 000 5 Star reviews
just take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz and GLG will create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
customized just for you with ingredients
that are dermatologist tested proven to
work and personalized for your needs for
Hair Care geology's got strengthening
shampoo and conditioner and co-wash
which will transform from your routine
and deliver the best hair of your life
it extends the time between washes and
replaces the need for so many products
so you wash your hair less and save
money they also offer body washes and
deodorants that are free of harsh
ingredients and smell great for skincare
they have you covered from all angles
fine acne reduce oiliness prevent
wrinkles combat dark or puffy under eyes
have smoother hydrated skin and Target
signs of aging their daily personalized
skincare routine comes with two face
washes morning face cream retinol night
cream and eye cream and right now for a
limited time you can get a five piece
trial set for only fifteen dollars if
you use the code rockstar70 at checkout
that's all for 50 a product for just
fifteen dollars on top of that you'll
get an additional bonus offer on one of
their brand new skin hair and body
products of your choice when you add it
to your trial to get started just click
the link in the description
my Army Koopas Goombas whatever those
things are oh we will destroy the
Mushroom Kingdom
in the following shots we get a closer
look at Bowser's troops from the party
scene we saw in a previous trailer I
putting out all the different types of
enemies we could see in that previous
breakdown but some of them get a special
shout out from King Bowser here you got
the Koopas which highlights the super
distinguished bloodthirsty red Koopa and
faithful blue paratroopa who we've
previously seen along with a Koopa
popping out of a piranha plant's mouth
for roll call also can someone take this
koopa's knife away who gave him that
like I know the rest of the army has
Spears but somehow a knife still seems
too far put it back P.S I didn't know
just how uncomfortable I was with Koopas
having teeth until this moment then we
have the Goombas with two of them giving
each other a headbutt which tracks
seeing as gumas are known to headbutt or
head bong at will and then there's this
dude using this other guy's head as a
chew toy finally we have to quote Bowser
whatever those things are to which I
immediately said spinies and then called
myself in a nerd and gave myself a
wedgie Bowser cries out that they will
destroy the Mushroom Kingdom and we can
see the star he's obtained just peeking
into frame above him we get our first
closer shot of a sledge bro and this
Goomba gets the kind of air time I wish
I could get at a concert Bowser is
coming I'm not afraid I'll do anything
for my brother we're going to save him
another shot of the interior of Peach's
castle reveals that the world map
actually Rises out of the sun detailing
again originally seen in Super Mario 64.
and you can see the Council of toads
that we saw in that previous trailer
beginning to gather around it we can
also see three paintings in the
background two of which look a lot like
the paintings we've seen in previous
trailers and the third being a snowscape
of some sort we're traded to two new
views that we haven't gotten to cover in
our breakdowns yet one being a field
with a cannon that is straight out of
Super Mario 64 and I believe this whole
scene is a nod to Bob on Battlefield
from the same game the cannon surrounded
by rocks in relation to the wooden ramp
with a box by it and a floating island
with a tree I'll see you Nintendo then
we see our first look at a desert-like
area whether it's the kingdom we see on
the world map I don't know kind of seems
like more of a montage moment but
regardless the upside down floating
pyramid Islands half buried pillars with
vibrant colors like toasterina town and
surrounding cacti tell me this was
highly influenced by the sand Kingdom
from Super Mario Odyssey
foreign
we then see Mario and Donkey Kong
gearing up to fight alongside each other
with Mario using a mushroom to grow to
Donkey Kong's height and Donkey Kong
obtaining a fire flower and gaining a
color palette that we haven't seen in
any previous games with frosted tips
that would make Lance Bass jealous
behind them we can see that they've
already been fighting with a passed out
Koopa and piranha plant in their wake
Mario Naruto runs off and then we see
them fighting all outside scroller style
across the kingdom okay back up in all
seriousness it's a cute detail that
Mario throws his arms out at top speed
since he started doing that way back in
Super Mario Bros 3 and has done it in
quite a few games ever since back to the
side scrolling part Mario kills a hammer
bro by hitting the block underneath it
much like the easiest way to kill them
in the games Donkey Kong's Forward Air
Attack that he doesn't Super Smash
Brothers and Mario's ground pound attack
that takes out a group of Koopas in the
back we can also see that the shop sign
has that same Super Mario Brothers 3
Treasure Chest symbol that we saw in the
ATMs in a previous trailer
here
here we
then we get to see where the cart
sausage is made and I knew they had to
have some kind of Black Market cart
dealership with the weapons on those bad
boys we can tell this Factory is still
in Donkey Kong Country and a lot of the
green and yellow detailing that we saw
in the stadium is used around here as
well and pink the green bumper sticker
with bananas on it on the cart in the
foreground that kind of matches the
flags around the stadium too we've
talked about the in-game carts that
inspired some of the cards we're seeing
here but some other fun details in this
place are the Kongs Crossing arms with
starting flags on the wall the wall
detailing of arms grabbing a wheel and
the cart part selector from Mario Kart 8
under each of the cart making sections
and this
[Music]
but then drama as we see for the first
time then Bowser's troops have taken the
wheel so to speak and they've got to
have their own Shady dealership because
some of these installations are crazy
that or they went on the Dark World web
worldwide the dark but really these
multi-shell firing weapons are intense
and seem to give green shells the
ability to not break upon first impact
what side note it seems like this is a
later continuation of the previous
trailer shot of Mario and the Gang along
with all the Kongs driving down Rainbow
Road in the daytime even later on you
can see the islands with palm trees in
the background and the water below them
and I like the detailing that when Mario
gets hit and falls from the Starry Sky
you can see when he lands that he is
actually farther down in the sky where
he's not surrounded by Stars anymore
which of course makes sense but I don't
know I like the spatial relativity okay
we also see the blue paratroopa driving
his own cart but like I said in a
previous video I would not be surprised
if we saw him hop out and turn into a
blue shell targeted at Mario eventually
yes
so Mario grabs onto this Bullet Bill
inspired bike and parkours his way over
to another cart making that classic jump
Sound by the way Stomps on this Koopa
which appropriately makes it Retreat
into its shell and then hurls his body
into his friend's car killing his friend
in a fiery explosion what an ending
Nintendo knows just what the kids want
and that's my friends is the final
official Super Mario Bros movie trailer
with that the countdown to April 5th
begins after seeing all of the trailers
and all the breakdowns what are you most
excited to see in this movie leave it in
the comments below do you think there
will be any wild card characters that
they haven't shown yet I'm rooting for
an after credit scene with the Rosalina
that sets up the sequel Marvel spoiled
me but if there will even be an after
credit scene we'll have to see until
then you can follow me on Twitter at
it'sanavanston and follow And subscribe
to new rockstars at new rockstars for
more breakdowns of everything you love
okay I leave you with a joke who's a
dentist Lisa favorite character in this
movie
DK
item out no laugh from the no laugh from
Dazzle all right
did you like that joke
DK
DK do you get it are we still recording
DK okay bye
[Music]